サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッタパリヨダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
講演を始める前に祝福しなくちゃいけないことがあります
今日の会場のお布施も先月と同じく大泉孝志さんのお布施で
今日のお話会が実現できることになりました
で 孝志さんが自分のご両親の祝福
と幸せ幸福を願って このお布施をしていただきました
で まあお父さんとお母さんのことを考えて
二回のお布施をしたかもしれませんけど
今日はお父さんということはないんだけど
まあ両親も一つワンセットですからね
今日の法性の功徳で そのご両親の方々方は大変幸福で安穏で清らかな心で生活できますように
早くも輪廻を脱出して解脱に達することができますようにと祈願祝福をいたします
それから大泉孝志さんにも心が清らかになりますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
自分の希望通りに物事がうまくいきますようにと
それから 心が煩悩の汚れからなくなって
清らかな心が現れますように
解脱に達することがこの功徳の力でできますようにと祝福いたします
皆様 三回サードを言ってください
サードサードサード はい
今日のテーマ始まります
体のトリセツって心のセクションが先月喋りましたからね
で 体に対して仏教はどんなアプローチでしょうかと
うーん これはちょっと勉強した方がいいんですよ
なぜならば 現代人は体のことしか考えてないんですね
要するに 自分自身で宣伝してないんだけど
みんなこの純物質論者ですね
いわゆる唯物質論者たちですね
体だけすごい気にするという
それで宗教の中になってくると
宗教もあまりにも体のことをね
あまり尊い大事にするような気配は見えてくるんですね
で だから そんな感情的に体を拝んで
肉体を神様に仕立てていいんでしょうかということもあります
仏教は科学者よりも厳密に厳しく
物事を科学的に見るんです
感情で判断することは一切ないんです
客観的に理性で物事を見るんです
だから 全く新興宗教から見ればまるっきり正反対で
宗教の敵ですよ で しかし
仏教は解脱の道をちゃんと教えます
じゃあまああの 難しくなるかどうか私もよくわかりませんだけど
一応続けてみましょう
できるだけ早く終了しようとは思っています
このタイトル考えてください
酸素に悩みがありますかと
ある？あるわけないでしょう
しかし 体の 65%酸素なんですね
半分以上でしょ 酸素は悩みませんね
苦しみもないね 楽しくなったり
興奮したりすることもありますかね
酸素なんか幸せを求めてハチャメチャ苦労するんですかね
酸素は65だから他はまたありますね
元素はね あの 記号書いたんだけどね
皆様 私化学知っていますからね
私は化学知らないんですね
これはカーボン 水素 窒素
カルシウム リン フォスファラス
カリウム サルファー ナトリウム
クロール マグネシウムというものごと元素なんですね
CL にはに入れるのは忘れちゃったんです
で この 11 は命にエッセンシャルエレメンツというんですね
普通は英語ではね いわゆるエッセンシャルでどうしても必要な 11 の元素でできているんですよ
まだありますよ 結構入って
これはトレースエレメンツといっても微妙にあるだけでね
時々細胞にものすごい猛毒になるものも微妙に入っている場合もあります
例えば放射物質とかね
ウランとかはあまり体に入ってないんだけど
あの 今我々は放射の中で生きているんだから
今の体を開けると もしかすると微妙に放射物質も見つかる可能性はありますけど
それはあの命を作るためにそんな何も仕事をしていないんです
この 11 の元素たちが頑張って
体を作っています だからこれには同じ質問でしょう
あの炭素でしたっけ？カーボンね
あの炭ですね 炭っていうと
そんなに悩んだり 苦しんだり
楽しくなったり 感情を引き起こしたりするんですかね
物質も有機体も老いたくない
死にたくない 死にたくはない
不死は無理なら長寿でも欲しいと思わないね
で 私たち この 11 の元素でできている私たちはどうですかね
あの物質に至るこれはね
有機体になっているんですね
それはちょっと違うんですね
化学物質としてはね 有機体っていうのはね
水と違うんですね 水は 2つの元素でできていますけど
有機体ではないんですね
だから有機物質どこかにあるからといってね
あー死にたくないわとか思う
そんなことはないんです
だったら皆様方はね ご飯に焼き魚を食べようと思ったら
焼き魚は有機体だからね
あー私は殺されてほしくないとか
もう食べられてほしくないという
そんなことはないんですね
物体だからね それで有機体にはこの感情はありません
それぐらいシンプル なことなんですね
だから体のことを気にするとかね
取りせすとかね ちょっと合わないんですね
仏教的にすごい残酷に物事を見てみると
まあ冷静に見てみると
しかし どう越した越して体のことは心配します
しかし 現実は何かというと
我々どう越して肉体のこと気にして心配しているんですね
なんかどうかなってますね
我々は またバッグが入っている
それからいきなりこの問題の答え出しましょう
感じるから命です 感じるというのはフィールフィールなんですね
俗世間のいうフィーリングではなく
基本的な働きですね これは皆様方は日本人だから
フィーリングといったらフィーリングといったら
なんか別な意味でとってますね
それじゃないんです 基本的な事象の意味でフィール
それは何を感じるんでしょうかというと
苦 楽 不苦楽という 3つです
だからこの 11の元素とは全く関係ない
11の元素にはありっこはないことがあるんですね
有体になったところで
それは苦 楽 不苦 不楽を感じるんですね
だから感覚を 3つに分けることは
お釈迦様にある理由があって分けてますけど
まあ普通ヴェーダなフィーリングだけでもよろしいとは思いますね
感じる 苦楽の判断は個人の問題にもなりますが
それはわかりますね 私が苦と感じても
同じ感覚には他の人は苦だと言わない可能性はあります
それは食べる物の場合はよく分かりますね
私が美味しいというのは楽を感じているんですね
でも 全ての人間がその食べ物に対して美味しいと感じてくれませんね
それから私自身でも 美味しいと感じる食べ物は
いつ食べても美味しいと感じるはずはないんです
ということは この苦楽を感じる場合は
科学性とかいわゆる数字で計算して科学的に分析する不可能なんです
数学組織に入らないんですね
例えば 私にとってリンゴがすごく美味しいと
いつだってリンゴを食べて美味しいと感じるわけないんですね
例えば 昨日 9時半でリンゴを食べて
すごい美味しいねと思ったことがあるということは
今日の 9時で午前 9時でリンゴを食べたら美味しく感じるかどうか
それはちょっとわからない
あるいは昨日は土曜日でしたから
毎土曜日 9時にリンゴを食べると
まあ美味しくてたまらんということあるかってわからない
科学的だったらぴったしした法則
方程式 これが必要なんですね
これがまるっきりないんです
全く科学的に数値データで理解することは全く不可能
まあわかりやすくいい加減ですね
中途半端ですね でと見えるんだけど
お釈迦様はそちら精密に科学的に分析しているんです
だからお釈迦様の科学は並みじゃないんで
もう桁違い科学なんです
科学者には絶対無理なことをやっているんです
それもまた精密に科学的に
だからそこでそのその人の内面の問題なんです
物質で説明できません
例えばリンゴは物質 体も物質
だから物質の中に何か物質を入れたら
出てくる答えはいつだって同じくないと
変です そうはなりませんね
そこで この個人の問題になりますがというところは説明しました
法則はありますね 愛着が生まれるものに楽という感覚なんです
拒否したくなる場合は
この感覚は嫌ですと自分の体に感覚が生まれたんです
自分の体に生まれた感覚をもう生まれて欲しくないんです
それに苦というんです
だから愛着が生まれるということは
欲が生まれる 拒否したくなるということは
怒りが生まれるんですね
無関心 気にしないという気持ちになったら
それは風来風楽というんです
その場合は 無知という煩悩が生まれるんです
無知ですね あんまり気にしない
調べない 興味ない そういうわけで
私たちには 3種類の感覚があります
要するに感じることが煩悩の入り口なんです
この有機体に感じるという能力が入って入ってしまって
そこからそれは窓口で入り口で
そこから膨大な煩悩が生まれるんです
生きることはそちらにあるんです
物質にあるわけじゃないんです
だから理性ある人は この肉体のことを全然気にもしないはずなんです
はい では 体の役割は何ですかね
こんなに大事にする すごい宝物扱いしている
世に一つしかないと思っている
この肉体の仕事は何でしたかね
役割はありません 残念でしたね
この有機体には何の役割もないんです
心が 心というのは知る働き
心が感覚を作るために道具として使っているだけです
心が体使っているだけで
体には何の？役割もないんです
まあ例えば あのロープがあるとしましょう
紐があるとしましょう
紐は私に大事な仕事がありますよと
ということはないでしょう
それで私がその紐を取って何か結んでおく
それは私 私がやったことであって
紐にとっては別にどうったことないんです
紐で物を結ぼうか 紐を燃やしてやろうか
ゴミ箱に入れようかと
紐関係ないんです 役割ないんです
で 心がこれだったらこういうことに使える
これならこういう風に使えるとかの心の判断でしょう
だから役割が心が決めるものであって
有機体なので 体が物質と違って簡単に壊れます
これ あの 65%の酸素かもしれません
それからたくさんなるのはカーボン
カーボンですね 炭素ですね
まあ次カルシウムでしょうと思いますけど
まあナトリウムも まあ結構重ちは結構ありますからね
そういうものは壊れません
大体は 例えば酸素には使用期限なんかある？ないんです
結構持ちます 炭素には？ある時間経ったら炭素でなくなるとか
それはないんです まあ永遠不滅じゃないんだけど
変化はするんだけど これは微妙な変化で
私たちにはそれはちょっとわからないぐらい
しかし この元素たちが集まって
この一般的にいうこの有機体になるんですね
有機体になると ハチャメチャたくさん元素が組み立てているんですね
やりすぎ 入れすぎ 例えばアミノとかね
そこ あの液入りちょっと見てください
ハチャメチャややこしいんですね
だから色々つなげたものを落ちるんです
だからギューッと硬くなってないんです
例えば鉄 物質の鉄だけ酸素と一緒になっちゃうと
フェリック酸化っていう
もういわゆる錆が現れるんですね
錆びた鉄は放っておくとどんどん酸素が出ていって
また元の鉄に戻る 戻れないんです
ものすごく頑丈で硬くて
そのままになるんです
だから 酸素が入った鉄分を純鉄分に作るためには
かなり苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
ものすごい苦労しなくちゃいけない
なのに この有機体はみるみるうちに壊れているんです
そこで心が この道具を修復します
だから体っていうのは心の道具なんです
で 例えば 命の一番単純な命っていうのは
単細胞の命とかバクテリアとかでしょ
そちらも心が働いているんです
だから壊れると何とかしようとするんです
だからバクテリアの命は短いんだけど
その短い時間で栄養を取ってるんです
うん 瞬間の休むこと ん？なんかおかしくなってます
瞬間の休むことがなく
修復作業をしなくてはいけないので
心に何の安らぎも落ち着きもありません
これで生きることがわかるでしょうね
我々には瞬間も暇がないんです
もう体を修復しなくちゃいけないんです
ものすごく壊れていくんです
なんかすごいなんか なんか話にならないんですよ
心が体を持ったんだけど
その瞬間からこれ修復してくださいと
そこで修復不可能で壊れるまで修復ばっかりやっているんです
結局は体を使う暇もないぐらいなんです
はい それで心 また貪瞋痴の無明という心にちょっとした問題があるんです
無明の役割があるんです
一般的に言う無知ですけど
もっと精密に仏教は無明という風に書くんですね
あの明というのは明りという意味というよりは
知恵という意味で パーリ語からサンスクリット語から日本語になっているんだからね
アヴィッジャアと言うんですね
ヴィッジャっていうのは知恵
アヴィッジャっていうのはない状態
知恵がない状態 対し修復作業に苦労しているので
体に執着することに意義があるのか
生きることに価値があるのか
物質の奴隷になることはいかがなものなのかと発見しないことは無明です
じゃあ無明の定義 何も発見しない
興味ない 例えば 体っていうのはハッチャン迷惑でしょうに
だって体のことを修復する
修復する 修復する 終わりなの
皆様方はそれをおかしいと思うかもしれませんだけど
皆様呼吸は 1 日何回休む？呼吸することは体修復していることと思ってないでしょ
思ってください 呼吸しなかったら死にます
死ぬっていうことは体壊れたっていうことでしょ
だから 1 日何回呼吸する？呼吸休んだことがある？暇がないでしょうよ
はい こんなことだったら呼吸と栄養も同じなんですよ
栄養っていうのは細胞たちに 24時間休ませる必要なんです
だから体の中でものすごい仕事が起きてるんです
胃袋に何か食物を入れて入れても
それは分解して体の栄養になるように
基本的な有機体に入れ替えちゃって
うん それはずっと絶えず運んでいるんです
酸素と一緒に ちょっとでもなくなったら
もうそこで壊れてしまいますよ
かなり危険状態なんですね
肉体は だったら何なのかこれをと考えた方がいいでしょう
考えない 体ほどありがたいことはないやとかね
皆様の間で人気あるヨガの世界でね
清らかな体で でなければ清らかな魂が宿りませんとかね
まあ信じられない嘘を言ってるんですね
そういうことで 心がそんなに物質の奴隷になって
瞬間も暇がなく物質のお世話をするという惨めなんです
心は これ物質だから 酸素だから
どうでもいいことでしょう
酸素と炭素だからもう放っておけば
心は奴隷なんですね やっぱり有機体をどんどん壊れるたびに新しく作って作って持っていくんです
だからそれに意味がないということは
調べないことが無明なんです
生きるために無明が欠かせないんです
だから体に役割はないんだけど
無明にものすごい役割が必要なんです
無明が生命を生かしているんです
生命がバカなことをやっているんだと理解させない
それちょっとごまかしておくんです
見るなよ それはと 命にこの上ない価値があるのだという錯覚を保つことが無明の役割です
だから 皆様の常識と全く違うことを私は言っていますよ
だから体に役割はありません
物質ですから しかし 無明に無知にすごい大事な役割があるんです
無明が命を作って 命に執着して生きりなさい
生きなさい 生きなさい
生きなさいと 言ってみてもろくなことはないんです
得るものは皆無 でも生きなさいよ
この生きることほどすごいことある？とかね
言われたら本当に生きることすごいことかと調べればいいのに
それは決してやらない
はい 次 あの命のことをさらに説明します
刺激のために生きる 我々はすっごく生きたがるんですね
生きたがるっていうことは
何のことかってみんなわかっていない
我々は本当は刺激が欲しいんですね
感覚を通して心が刺激を求めます
そこで心がこの物体に感覚能力を上げる
この感覚から刺激が生まれるんです
あの水素に刺激がないんです
炭素にも刺激がないんです
感覚から生まれるんです
刺激が生まれても 体の水素には全然関係ないんです
刺激は心を回転するために必要なエネルギーです
刺激が入ると心が回転するんですね
この回転といって同じ心を回るっていう意味じゃなくて
心っていうのは瞬間に死ぬんです
瞬間に死んだら新たな心を作るんです
それで瞬間死んで新たな心を作るんです
だから この消滅を続けなくちゃいけないことになっているんです
エネルギーがあるから
新しい心が生まれるんです
で それに生き続けるということを言ってるんですね
ですから 体を捨ててはならないことになっちゃうんです
だって 体から刺激が生まれるんだと
それ嘘ですけど 体に刺激がないんだけど
感覚の問題ですけど まあ無明だからそう思ってるんですね
無執着になるのではなく
力強く体に執着しなくてはならないというかわいそうな結果になるんです
もうハチャメチャ間違いで嘘なんですね
肉体には刺激が生まれるはずがないんです
感覚がなければ まあ四十兆ほどの細胞があると言っているでしょう
細胞たちに感じる能力はあるんです
酸素にはない 元素にはないんです
だから この 間違って体に執着するんですね
力強く体に執着する 執着するんです
体がなかったら何にもできなくなるんだと
本当にそうなのかと この気持ちで死ぬまで体の維持管理をしています
だから生きるっていうことは
本当に惨めで無意味で
生きるとは あなた死ぬまで体を維持管理してくださいなんです
それ心がそれをやっているんです
例えで考えましょう 例えば
あの どこかずっと水が流れている
上から水かけて ずっと
これはもう限りなく流れている
そこで誰かが この例えば岩の上で流れている
この岩をきれいにして拭いて
こちらに座ろうではないかと思って
水を全部拭いて拭いてあげるんです
大きいタオルとか何とか持ってて
拭いても拭いても水が流れてくるんです
で また拭く また水が流れる
また拭く またタオルで絞ってまた拭いちゃうとまた水が流れている
岩の上に軽く水が流れているんだったら
この人にそれ拭いて拭いて拭いて
もう乾いた岩にして座れる？これ
死ぬまでやったっても同じことでしょう
例えばその水がもう川があって
川の流れのほんのちょっと横に流れてくることとしましょう
これって個人には止まることはできないでしょ
だから この無知な人をやるべきことは諦めることなんです
この岩は乾いた状態にして
気持ちよく座って弁当を食べようという
これは一切ありえないんです
諦めた方がいいんです
死ぬまで拭いたっても終われないんです
我々はそれをやっているんです
生きる生きる生きるということで
だからあまりにも無知でしょ？この気持ち
死ぬまで体の維持管理をしています
自然法則である老いること
病と また死は決して受け止めたくはありません
要するに真理を拒否します
嘘だったらはい どうぞと受けて受ける
事実を言うと ものすごく拒否して
昔なら殺される 本当のことを言う人は
今それはちょっと難しいんだけど
その代わりに もう本当のことを言う人はものすごく非難侮辱をする
だから今まで私が喋ったことも
社会人からものすごく拒絶反応を起こす非難侮辱を受ける言葉なんです
例えばこの有機体だから
あまりにも元素を複雑に組み立てているんだから
1個 2個ポロポロと落ちるんです
あのケミカルボンドといいますけど
このそんなに強くつなげてないんです
例えば水素と酸素がつなげているような感じで
もの強力につなげてないんです
切り離せないように というわけで
その有機体に有機体としての能力があっても
それはどんどん減っていく
それから壊れていく それから何の役にも立たないものに戻す
有機体っていうのは 純物質にはなかなか変わりませんだけど
できるだけこの自然法則でこのリサイクルするんですね
ギリギリまでリサイクルするんです
人間よりは優しいんです
例えば枯れ葉がありますね
それも有機体でしょ 人間だけ枯れ葉を燃やしちゃうんだけど
これって残酷な行為で
枯れ葉を捨てたら 土に戻りませんね
有機体はちょっと変わって変わって変わって
別な有機体になって また新たな有機体を作るために協力するんです
いわゆるリサイクル だから我々はキャベツを食べて
ジャガイモを食べて ご飯を食べて
ただリサイクルするんです
リサイクル工場なんです
人間以外生命が死んじゃったら
あの有機体をリサイクルに回すんです
人間だけ残酷で 人間の体は燃やしちゃうんです
あのチベット仏教でね
チベット仏教というか
チベットではね なんかあの鳥葬という葬式方法があるんだそうですね
今もやっているかどうかよくわかりませんだけどね
あれって NHK かどうかで放送してね
かなりの行きづらいところでね
まあもういくらでも金あるんだから
あのグループは行けますけどね
で あれはイギリスで撮ったものを自分で撮ったような感じで
だいたい NHK のほとんどそうなんです
ヨーロッパ イギリス スイスグループがそれを撮って
自分で新しい場所をそこで出すだけ
で 本当にいろいろもうパクりでね
もう裁判かけなくちゃいけないんだけど
裁判かけられないように
まあする賢くごまかししています
私は騙せれませんからね
日本人騙してもらえば十分でしょうかね
これはあちらから取ったでしょうとかね
ようわかります はい その鳥葬という場合は
遺体を何かすごい高い高い山のところに持っていって
そこでものすごいいろんな道具があってね
刃物があって 遺体を砕いて砕いて砕いて
外岩の上に出しておくんです
それでハゲタカ ワシとか来て
肉を持っていって食べるんです
だからあのアホな連中思っているのは
この魂ができるだけ天に近いところに持っていった方がいいやと
だったら魂をハチャメチャ砕いたらどうするんですかね？後でどうやって繋げるんですかね
わしがイチロクチリと糞を出しますからね
だからそれで考えれば何の意味もないんだけどね
肉食べたらもうすぐ鳥だからね
あっという間に糞を出しちゃいますね
それはドカンとまた地面に落ちるんだだからね
天国に行けないと思いますけど
しかし 別な意味でみると正しいことをやっているんです
この有機体だから 借りたものだから返すんです
リサイクルに回すんです
私たちの体が鶏やらね
魚の死骸やらとかね そんなものを入れて入れてリサイクルしていますね
いわゆる人間という有機体を作っているんですね
魚の細胞じゃないんで
こちらに入ったら細胞を分解して
アミノ酸とか必要なものを取り取ってもらう
で この体の細胞を作るんですね
だから借りているんですね
だからこれもちゃんと返さなくちゃいけないんです
自然界では このリサイクルプログラムはものの見事に言ってますね
で それはどういうことかというと
このやっとこの地球の変化によってやっと現れたんですよ
この有機体 最初の有機体は
結構苦労したんです だからそれを無駄にしないで
ずーっとリサイクルでいっちゃいます
はい そういうわけだから
この有機体の自然法則っていうのは
これは壊れる また分解できる
至って単純 私たちには鶏の死骸を人間の体に入れ替えることは至って簡単単純にできるんです
もし鶏の死骸が石のようで
溶岩のように硬くてものすごい変化しないものだったらどうしますか？だから有機体が簡単に壊れることが
命のために必要なものなんです
それは本当にありがたいことなんです
そこで我々食べるものはすぐ悪くなって
なってしまうものだったら
体にそれは一番栄養が受けやすいんです
まあ例えばね まああの洋ナシとかありますね
もう熟したらもうすぐ次の日もうもう腐りかけているんですね
ああいうのは食べたらすぐ体に消化するんです
保存食でもね 我々は食べる場合は簡単に壊れるようにまたチェンジして食べるんです
あの 何でしたっけ 大根
なんか干し線みたいなして
なんかあれはあれ何て言いますか
切り干し大根 あれはあれは食べられませんね
それをまた水に戻してなんとかするんです
そうすると早く悪くなるんです
早く悪くなる状態にしてから食べるんです
だから壊れることっていうのはありがたいでしょうに
生きることありがたいんだったら
なのに人間どういうことかというと
老いることは嫌いです
何考えてるんですかね
病は嫌いです 病いっていうのは何か機能うまく機能しないんですね
それが当たり前で 有機体だから
そんなに嫌いなら自分の体
純鉄で造ってもらったら？あるいは純酸素で造ってもらったらどうですかね
純炭素で作ってもらったら
炭素ならまあもう 1万年
2万年って軽々と 持ちます
燃やさない限りは そういうことで
無明っていうのはそういうとこなんですね
生老病死っていうのは自然法則
それは特に有機体の場合は自然法則
物質にもあるんだけど
すっごく時間かかるんです
地球はやがてきれいさっぱり消えますよ
別のエネルギーに変わります
が もうどれぐらい時間かかるかとね
これはちょっと我々の短い命ですから
かんかず具合 はい 次 感情の暴走っていうテーマで考えましょう
良い感覚を感じたい 良い刺激を受けたい
悪い感覚を避けたいという衝動に制限がありません
心って無明で無知でアホだから
心が刺激が欲しい 自分が回転するために
刺激なら良い刺激くださいと
これにリミットがない
いくらでもいいやと それで悪い刺激はとにかく攻撃してやめたいと
そちらもリミットがないんですね
しかし 眼耳鼻舌身の能力に制限がありますよ
我々はどこから刺激を受けますか？眼耳鼻舌身で刺激を受けているんです
身というのは体 体から刺激を受ける
目から刺激 耳から刺激を受ける
そちらに違う違う感覚が生まれる
互い違い感覚 それはまあただ名前だけで
だから舌で感じるものに
舌の感覚に味という本当は感覚なんです
耳の感覚に聴覚という
ただの感覚なんですね
パーリ語でもソータ ヴェーダナーと言いますよ
ソータ サンパッサジャ ヴェーダナーと言うんですけど
しかし リミットがあるでしょ
どう見ても体で感じられるもの
耳で感じられるもの 目で感じられるもの
リミットがあります この間読んだ本で
この光と関係ある波長は全部まとめて書いてあって
あのあれ 画像があって
これぐらい長いんですね
その中でほんのちょっとだけですね
人間に見えるの なんか恥ずかしくてたまらん
これぐらい大きく書いて
ほんの真ん中ちょっとこれだけ人間に見えますよと
だからそこを見てもリミットがあるでしょう
世の中でいくら味があっても
我々が感じる味っていうのはほんのわずかなんです
うん 物質には限りのない力を発揮することは不可能です
物質のエネルギーはいつでも決まっているんです
それは科学者にも計算できます
一般人の意 私は現に身心で一寸で一寸で止めたんだけど
本当は 6つあります 現に身心
意 心 一般人のいのちからも微々たるものです
だから思考を働かせて刺激を作ることはできます
体でなくても でもあれって一般人が心成長していないと
心はすごく能力をアップしていないと
大した刺激は入りません
で 心妄想だけで刺激を受けちゃうと
体が全体的に壊れるんです
だからほとんどの人間の 98%以上精神的に病気なんです
妄想ばっかりしているんだから
でもそれは刺激でしょ
精神病にかかっている人も
あれで生きているんです
くだらない暗い妄想しながら生きているんです
事実を求めたくない心が不満を感じます
だから心は事実を否定する
拒否する だから不満だ
これはと 目でいろんなものを見たいんだけど
見られないんだから不満を感じる
世の中でいろんな音があるのに聞こえないんだから不満を感じる
例えばこのクジラなんかはなんかすごい歌ってるみたいですね
人間には聞こえません
そこはこの人間の音楽世界との比較できるかできないぐらいかなり進んでいるみたい
彼とにかくその音波を機械で受け取って受け取って
科学者が分析するんですね
そうするとこの 決まってる歌があったりして
そこで突然新しい曲を作るんだそうです
だから一人のクジラが新しい曲を作って
それを歌っちゃうと これはもう何 100キロも水を通って音がいくんです
波長がすっごい超音波だからね
かなり遠く来るんです
そうすると他のクジラたちもそれを覚えて合唱で歌うんだそうです
だから かなりクジラたちの歌の世界が
歌の文化があるんです
クジラたちもそれぞれの気持ちやら
いろんなことを表現するために歌っているんです
だから この人間にはいくら科学的な機械があったとしても
それを聞くことはできない
ただ機械でデータだけ取って
データのこの音楽的な
この何か法則に法則があるんだから
合わせてみると これはいくらなんでもミュージックだと
で決めるしかないんですね
そこで皆様 そのお話は前もって聞いたことあると思いますけど
あの そんなにすごい歌を歌ってますかね
クジラが 聴きてみたいなね
と思っちゃうでしょ でも絶対聞こえないと聞いちゃうと
なんとなく 英語のデフという耳が機能しない
だからクジラから見れば人間はデフなん
デフって何でしたっけ？日本語で
音難聴じゃなくて聞こえない状態
聴覚障害  とにかく聞こえない
だからクジラが人間のことをあいつらに音を聞こえないと思ってるでしょうね
例えば人間がモグラ モグラかわいそう
目が見えないねとか言ってるでしょ
どちらかわいそうかよくわかりませんだけどね
クジラも人間のことをそう思ってるでしょうね
我々のシャチの音もキリキリキリって音出す
それしか聞こえてないでしょ
あれは全然気持ち悪いんで美しくないんです
音は出してますけどね
それでまたあの聞いた話ですけど
ゾウも結構お互い喋ってるみたいんです
しかし ゾウはたまに人間に聞こえる声も出します
それはかなり強烈ですけどね
ビビっちゃいますけどね
で 普段は普通喋ってるみたいですね
人間に聞こえない ゾウさんたちはちょっと低音
低音波を使っているみたいですね
ローフリークエンシー使っているみたい
で ネズミがね かなりハイフリークエンシーで音を出してます
人間に聞こえない それはそこまでいかなくてもいいんです
そんなものは我々には存在しないんだからね
私たちの眼耳鼻舌身意がすごく能力決まっている
物体だから それに心が不満を抱くんです
心が体に能力を超えた働きを期待します
それで我々の心が体に期待するんですね
体に期待する これは能力を超えたものを期待するんです
それでさらに心に悩み
苦しみが生まれるんです
そういうわけでもっと良いものがあるはずという生き方になるんです
何かを見る 少々楽しいが納得いかない
我々の毎日のこと 何か見たら
あ いいねとかね じゃあ楽しくなるんで
でも 納得いかない 例えばこの花を見たって
あー結構すごい綺麗という風にはないでしょ
なんとかまあいいんじゃない？っていうと
納得いってないんです
もっと良いものがあるはず
それ探しましょうと はちゃめちゃなことをする
何かを見る 楽しくない
それで良いものがあるはずと思っちゃうんです
何か見たら楽しくない
え？良いものあるはずよ
それを探しましょう 何かを見る
楽しくなる そうすると続けて見る
それで飽きるんです 飽きちゃったらもっといいものがあるはず
探しましょう これでしょう
我々の人生は なんかカラスみたいにスズメたちみたいにいつでも何か探っている
カラスやらスズメたい鳥にも
ハトとかのはね あまり餌がないんだだからまたすぐ食べなくちゃいかんでしょ
だから探すは探すを探すを探すを探す
すごい苦しい生き方なんですよ
お腹いっぱい食べることはできない
お腹いっぱい食べたからといって
大した量がお腹に入らないんですよ
それですぐ消化して出しちゃうんです
また探さなくちゃいけないんです
でも見つからない 私たちも同じことをやっているでしょう
食べすることは一応人間が問題解決しているんだからね
しかし 現に出身で刺激を探す探すことはきりがなく
もっといいものがあるはず
そこでどんな条件でも結論は同じになるでしょう
私はそういう計算して書いたんです
何か見てちょっと楽しくなると
ほんのちょっと足らない
もっといいものがあるはずで探す
あるいは何か見た 楽しくないだったらもっと楽しくなるものあるはず
探す あるいは何かを見て楽しくなる
楽しくなっちゃうとさらに見る
さらに見ると刺激が出てこなくなっちゃって飽きてしまうんです
そうするともっと別なものがあるはず
また探す 結果同じなんです
六根において この既定のプログラムが起動しています
これは規定プログラムです
プリインストールしているんです
逃げられません 探す 探す
探す 探す 探す 現に出身で
から刺激を探しているんです
その問題 心にあるんですよ
だから心が限りのない刺激を欲しがる
しかし この道具にはリミットがある
はい そこで人間の次の罠
もっと働けという罠に引っかかっちゃうんです
何かを見る 楽しくなる
さらに見る 楽しい 夢中になる
目の能力 リミットが超えているのに気づきません
ちょっと別なケースなんですね
これは 例えば 子供たち
ゲームやったりして目が悪くなってるでしょ
あれ大人もそうでしょう
耳が悪くなってるって
音楽聴きすぎちゃって
味覚が派手に鈍感になってるでしょ
だってものすごい色んな味つけてつけてつけて
特に日本料理ではものすごい塩と砂糖を使ってるでしょ
あれかなり危険ね 味としては
皆様方は一度も大根の味を知らないと思います
だって大根料理は結構あるでしょ？派手に味つけるんです
だから生では大根おろしっていうものを食べてるかもしれませんだけど
でも醤油かけるでしょ
そのまま大根おろしを食べることはしない
私以外は そこで大根の大根おろしは別なものなんです
大根おろし 醤油かけないで食べたからといって
同じ味ではないんです
だから大根かじってほしいんです
そうするとまずいと思うでしょ
あれは味覚が壊れてるからなんです
だから私個人から個人の世界だからね
私個人で大根おろしをそのまま口に入れて食べるんだけど
よく理解できない なんでお醤油かけるのかと
え？なんで？とか よくわからない
だから文化的な人間が
食文化ある人間が 結局は味覚を求めて求めて求めて体壊してるんです
体の味覚を感じる あの有機物体が壊れて機能ほとんどするしない状態になってるんです
目を使いすぎて目の力が落ちている
私の目の力もかなり落ちてますけど
あの まあそれも本当に使いすぎなんですね
パソコン画面に目をつけたままで貼り付けちゃって
それでかなり壊れたんですね
今年ですから 年のせいで衰えることはあります
それはあんまり問題ではありません
目にそれから楽しい刺激を作ることができなくなるんです
目はどうこすって使っちゃうと目にはリミットあるんだから終わっちゃうんです
例えばボールペンだったら
もう 1ヶ月使っても2ヶ月使っても使えるんですね
必要な時 何か書くとなれば
ある人がボールペンを持って
もう紙もたくさん持ってきて
ゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ落書き書いて書いて書いて走り書き回しちゃう
もう落書きでもなく ただゴチャゴチャ書けばいいでしょう
そうすると 1時間以内でボールペンがアウト
ボールペンの能力は終わっちゃった
必要なメモだけ書く場合は
これ結構持ちますね  子供たちにはね
ちっちゃな子供たちにそういうゴムゴムをね
いろいろパステルとかね
まあ何かあげちゃうと
あっという間に消えちゃうでしょ
また買ってあげなくちゃいけないんです
なんであの子供たちから見たら
もう書くわ書くわ書くわ
はちゃめちゃもうくだらんことばっかり書いてるんだけど
使いすぎちゃって 早く使えなくなっちゃうんですね
また買ってあげなくちゃいけない
それで我々大人が原理主義出身を使いすぎ
だから体の機能が壊れているんです
六根においてこのプログラムを起動させる人もいる
はい それは全てということじゃないんです
もっと探そう もっと探そうっていうことは全てなんです
この一つやりすぎ 凝っちゃって
六根を悪用するのは する人もしない人もいる
ゲームやって １時間やったんだから
目が疲れるんだから休みましょうとかね
他のことをしましょうとかね
そういうふうな自己管理する人もいるんですからね
この人々は体を悪用しています
だから これで体を悪用するグループが現れてくるんです
修復が不可能になると
極端に悩む 苦しむ 自分に悪用したんだから仕方がないでしょ
糖尿病になったらあなたのせいと言った方が正しい親切な言葉でしょう
これ言っちゃうと差別になっちゃうんです
私は本当は言いたいんだけどね
糖尿病になると あなたのせいで性格悪いんだからね
だから自分がやったことだから
自分で報いを受けてくださいと言った方が正しいんです
でもそれ失礼だと思ってるでしょ
あれは無用のせいなんです
失礼じゃないんです 現実なんです
そこで味覚を悪用して体が壊れたらまた悩むんです
なんかお坊さんだから何かおまじないでもないんですかね
感想が水晶が元に戻してくれるとかね
そういうふうに迷信に走るんです
本当はないんですね 残念ですけど
というのは というわけで
人間というのは体のトリセツは知らないんです
自転車は上手に上手に乗れるという理由で
飛行機の操縦するとどのような結果になるでしょうかね
俺にできます なんで私は自転車だったらものの見事になる
乗れますよ そう だから飛行機の操縦任せてくださいと
任せ 我々それやってるんですよ
体に対して 食べる場合は美味しいから食べる
味覚の刺激を求めて食べる
満足しようと食べる これありえないんですが
やってるんでしょ？美味しくないと食べないでしょ
だから食べる時の皆様の狙いは美味しくなければいけませんと
これは飛行機の操縦と同じです
自転車に乗る人が 摂取とは体という機械に燃料を入れることなのに
その決まりを忘れているんです
だからまるっきり無妙で無知で
もう非科学的で 美味しいから食べる
これは目が見えない人は世の中に色がないということとおかしと同じことなんです
生まれつき目の障害の人が色なんかあるわけないでしょうにと
だって私はみんな赤いという色を
紙を触ってみて みんな白いと紙を触ってみたんで
同じことでしたからね
何も差はなかったと だから色は存在しないとかいうような
目が見えないだけでしょう
だから人類は 生命は目が見えないんです
美味しいから食っちゃうんです
結局動物の方がマシですね
動物は美味しいから食べてないんです
動物の餌は決まってるんです
決まってる餌はもうとにかく食べるよ
だって蛇がね カエルを丸飲みしているでしょ
あれ 美味しい？蛇にもベロありますよ
それは面白いこと 人間のベロよりは感度すごい微妙なんです
そこら辺に人がいるんだとかね
蛇がいるんだって ベロで知るんです
だから我々の舌よりは進んでいるでしょ
でもアイツは カエルが美味しいと知ってる？美味しいと知るわけないで
そのままガブガブと飲み込んじゃうんだから
でもあの食べ方が科学的に正しいんです
だから一回カエルさんを見つけて飲み込んだら
あれをきれいに消化するまでまた食べない
賢いでしょ だからヘビは糖尿病にはならない
人間飼ってない限りは太ったりもしない
日本の動物園にいる動物たちがみんな気持ち悪い
みんな太ってるんです
無理やりものを食わして食わして食わして
で 人間がこの刺激に騙されちゃって
心が暴走しちゃって 感動が暴走しちゃって
感動というか この刺激
感覚ね 欲しい欲しいってことになっちゃって
真理からきれいに完全に脱出しているんです
体が物体として見ていないんです
燃料を入れすぎか 使用不可能な燃料を入れてますね
だから我々人間が食べる時は燃料を入れすぎ
これ危険でしょ あるいは合わない番号の燃料を入れてるんです
ガソリン車ですけど ディーゼル入れている
ディーゼルエンジンですけど
ガソリンを入れるようなことをやっている
やってない？やってますよ
自分の体にまるっきり合わないものを食べているんですね
体の取り扱いを知らないようなタイトルですね
原理 鼻 接近 胃に色相 香
味 触法という情報を入れる時
刺激 感情を求めているならば
その人の体の使用方法は間違っているんです
これで刺激を求めてはならないんです
本当は わずかな時間だけ刺激を受けるかもしれませんが
体を壊しているので激しく悩む
苦しむ羽目になるんです
あの刺激っていうのはすぐ消えちゃうんです
例えば何か見て すごい
あ なんて綺麗ですかと感動するでしょ
あれ一回で消えるんです
それから別にっていうことになっていくんです
それがその通りなんです
例えば このホールに入った時は
皆様外から来たんだから
ホールの形を見たらなんとなく気持ちが変わっちゃうでしょ
でも 2 3 分であれが忘れちゃうんですね
もう刺激が消えるんですよ
それが事実 しかし 刺激が欲しい
刺激が欲しいという あれが完全間違いなんです
それで必ず体が壊れる
体っていうのは有機体だから
単純にシンプルなことで壊れるのです
もっと頑丈な体があった方が良かったという不満もありますね
みんなそう思ってるでしょ
もっと頑丈な もっとしっかりした体があった方がいいんじゃない？とかね
誰だって面白いね 自分の体に不安を持ってるんです
相当変なんです だって体一個しか一体しかないでしょうに
これは比較することできないでしょうに
あの人はどんな刺激感じるかっていうことは私にはわからないでしょうに
なのに自分の体に不安を持って
あの人の体なら羨ましいねとかね
それはどういうことかとわからないはずなんですけど
人間みんな自分の体に不満を持ってるんです
はい これで一旦休憩にして
体の使い方を説明します
はい では始まります それらの今まで我々は体の扱い使い方を知らないという話になりましたね
それはかなり詳しく説明したはずですけど
はい 私だけ喜んでいるわけじゃないしね
理性のある人はね 物事を客観的に
科学的に 感情を抜いて事実として見る人は
体は幸福への道案内するんですね
理性があれば その人の体がその人に幸福の道案内してあげるんです
うん で さっさと説明していきます
ステージ１続編 要するに一般の誰だってこれやった方がいいっていうことなんです
理性を使って体が純有機物体であることを理解する
これしなきゃどうにもならん
体尊いものでもありがたいものでもどうでもなくて
ただの機械ですね これ
有機物体なんですね そうするとどんな風に取り扱えばいいかとかわかるんです
物質を自分勝手に管理できるものではないと理解する
すぐわかることは これは有機物体です
私が好き勝手に いじることはできませんと
そちらには法則があるんだよと理解することです
有機物体の制限を理解する
それから制限も理解する
例えば 皆様よく知ってるでしょ？水の中に潜ることは
まあ 2 分程度にしましょうとね
じゃあ私は 10 分は水の中に入ってるぞって
誰もやらないね それで問題起きてないでしょ？なんで？なんでそのように体の制限を知らないんです？言ってください
耳にもこれぐらいの音を聞ければ十分だ
これ以上やっちゃうと壊れますよと
目はこれ以上使っちゃうと壊れますよと
鼻はこれ以上使っちゃうと壊れますよと
例えば鼻の味覚というんだか
その能力っていうのは 2 分で消えるんですよ
だから 匂いや香り感じるの
ほんのわずかな時間なんです
それで鼻が麻痺するんです
いわゆる閉めるんです
それ以上に恐ろしいな
もっと恐ろしい もっと恐ろしいな
匂い嗅いでやろうではないかと
これはもうやめた方がいいんです
道具の正しい使い方を学んでわがままを捨てる
だから体が道具であると
知っておけば わがままを捨ててほしい
わがままを捨てるだけで
かなり体の管理できるようになります
また続きあります 続編の
で 感覚と刺激を作る目的で体を使っているのだと理解する
私は何のために体を持っているかと
これ感覚を作るためやと
刺激を作るためやと ただそれだけやと理解してください
例出します 食べる時 体に必要な物質を必要な量のみを入れる
だから刺激求めちゃうと壊れますよと
感覚を求めちゃうと これ悪用であると
これ機械だから 自分の好みで
気持ちで 欲望で 妄想で使えないんです
例えば この 13倍して自動販売機に行ってね
あのコーラの代わりに百万札束が落ちてほしいと思ってもね
まあ気持ちはわかりますけど
落ちて悪くないんだからね
でもそんな 100円入れてボタンを押したら
100 万札束が落ちることはありえないでしょうに
だからリミットを知りましょう
ご飯食べるっていうことは
楽しいから食うんじゃないんです
美味しいから食べるんじゃないんです
誰だって12時に昼ご飯食べるから食うんじゃないんです
なんてことでしょうかと思いますけど
誰だって朝目が起きたら朝ご飯食べるもんやとかね
変な決まりは決まりばっかりなんです
だから まあ癖になってるんだから
ちょっと微妙に難しいんだけど
理解しておけばどこかで微妙に管理できるんです
朝目が覚めておいたら
全身体に栄養が必要という感じじゃないんだったら食べなくてもいいんです
それでもマンネリで食べるんだと理解した上で
実は朝食べなくてもいいんだけど
まあ毎日やってるんだから
じゃあちょっと食べましょうという風に
そこでいくらか体管理するんですよ
壊れないようになるんです
一旦出かけたら まあずっと 3時まで仕事終わるんだと
昼ご飯食べる時間もないんだと
ああ それだったら今お腹が空いてなくても食べた方がいいとかね
そういう風にも計算してみた方がいいでしょうね
我々はこの瞑想会で修行会やると教えているんです
食べる時はこういうことを観察しなさいと
人間がね 一番問題を起こしているのは食べる時なんです
限りなく刺激を求めるのではなく
体が与える刺激で満足する
納得する これはすごい大事なポイントで
刺激禁止と言っているわけじゃないんです
刺激が禁止と言ったっても
刺激が起きるんだからね
あのキリスト教の修行者みたいじゃないんです
キリスト教の修行者たちが
あの 皆さんはあまり知らないんだけど
一般人は入れてくれないし
隠れたところで激しく苦行生活
失笑の生活をしているんですね
刺激禁止 テレビ見るなよ
音楽を聞くなよとかね
音楽だったらもう神を讃嘆する賛美歌だけにしなさいとかね
あれってまあリチュアルで地獄に行くんだからね
まあいいんだけどね くだらないことをやってアホなことをやるとアホなところに行くんだから
そんなことなく すごく普通に生活すればいいんです
常識的に  何か口に入れちゃうと
なんか美味しく感じてしまうんです
別にそれはいいんで 別に
あ これ美味しいんだからもっと食え
もっと食べます あれやめてほしい
何かで美味しかったよ
それで終わり だから今度も持ってきてちょうだいではダメなんです
今度も 同じものを買うっていうことはダメなんですね
だから例えば自分の舌がどんな程度で味を感じさせてくるかということは
これは個人差があります
で 例えば我々インド系
インダ文化系だから インド料理文化に馴染んでいるんですね
だからそちらの方が美味しいと感じるようにプログラムを組み立てて
私は今ないんだけど あの
もう普通の人間だったらね
日本に住んでいるスリランカ人が
20年住んでいてもスリランカ料理しか食べないんです
面白くてしょうがないんです
この連中は長い間日本に住んでいるのに
日本の日本食食べないでしょうとね
なんてアホアホでしょうかと
だからそれはやっぱり
まあ自分が決めた刺激に
こだわっているということでね
だからこの味覚っていうのは人によって違います
だから私にはあの人と同じく感動しておいしく感じることはできません
ある人が何か何ておいしいですとか
涙まで来るかも だから私もそれ食べたら自分にもこの涙が出るぐらいおいしさを感じたけど
これは感じませんよ だから理性のある人は
自分が感じる味覚で おいしさで
まあこれで納得する まあ私にとってはこんな程度だと
これでいいんじゃない？ということで
ここでストップしてください
それで体正しく使えるんです
世にはいろんな音楽がある
どんな音楽も我々は楽しくならないんです
だから自分が楽しい気分になる音楽を聴いて
他の音楽も聴いても まあそれほど楽しくはならないね
私には それは理解すればいいでしょうに
なんでこれは？とかね
なんだこの音楽 うるさい
やめなさいとかね あれはダメなんですね
自分にとってはそんなに美しく感じないんですねと
そこで納得すれば そこで自分が感動する音楽でも少々聴いて
感動してストップしなくちゃいけない
飽きるまでやっちゃうともったいないんです
また二度とあの曲が聞こえなくなっちゃうんだから
だから飽きる前にちょうどいいところで止めてほしいんです
これは食事でわかりやすいんですね
我々に出家にお釈迦様が言っているのは
お腹が満足する前に あと八口ぐらい食べられますよと
そういうところでストップしてくださいと
ストップして もっと食べられるのにとかね
まだ満腹になってないって不満があるんですね
それでお釈迦様の指令だから
残りは水を飲むんですね
水を飲んでしまうと 物質的に胃が満腹なんです
しかし たくさん入れてないんですね
そうすると 心に次の食事も気持ちよく食べようというエネルギーが残っているんです
だから体壊れないんです
次の食事時間になってくると
体が準備OKなんです
受けてやろうと で 朝食べて食べて食べまくっちゃうとすべて壊れちゃうんです
朝食べまくっちゃったならば
一日食べないでいた方がよろしいんです
次の日も朝ごはんを食べないで
昼まで待った方がいいんです
なぜならば 体が燃料を入れる準備を整えるまで
で それで苦しい？苦しくないんですよ
それで納得すれば 理性使っちゃえば
俺は賢いやと アホじゃないやと思っちゃえば
俺は豚じゃないやと 出すもの何でも食っちゃうとかね
そういう風に理性使っちゃうと何でもできるんです
だから目で見える ある程度で見て
はい まあこれで十分 だから明日も美しいものを見るように準備整えて
壊れ目が壊れないようにしておく
映画見るからといって
で ネットでね まあ 8時半
午後 8時半に映画見始めて
いくらでもあるんだから
朝 7時まで見ちゃうと
とんでもないことでしょ？それで目が壊れるだけじゃなくて
脳みそも壊れるでしょ
だったら  1週間に一回程度で
ネットでいくらでもね
まあ今映画あるんだからね
AMAZON だったらね
AMAZON プライムでね
いくらでも出してるんだからね
無料で だから 1週間 1本ぐらい見て
それは思い存分見てほしい
ああ面白い 面白いとかね
はちゃめちゃ猿みたいに手を叩きながら見たってもいいんです
ゲラゲラ隣に迷惑をかけるぐらい笑って見たってもいいんです
だって思い存分楽しいもん
時間終わった  1時間終わった途端
キシッと言って それからまた来週ということにすれば
私もアマゾンプライムは持っているんだけど
一年一本も見てないんです
お金払ってるだけで たまに誰かが来たらね
まあ出して見て 好きなもの見てくださいと出してあげるだけで
で 皆様はそんなことする必要はない
映画見てもいいんです
音楽聴いてもいいんです
コンサートに行ってもいいんです
しかし 程度知って 喜びを麻痺しない程度でストップして
そこで満足してほしい
この満足する習慣がないんですね
それは道具を丁寧に使うことなんです
包丁は切れるんだからといって
もう何でも何でも何でも切る切る
これはちょっと 包丁にしたってもいろんな種類があるでしょうに
だから加工包丁で何を切るのかどうかね
あるんですからね 例えば刺身包丁というものがあって
それで玉ねぎみじん切りできることはできるんだけど
ちょっとまずいんですね
うまくいかないんですね
それで普通のキッチン包丁で刺身作ろうかなと思っちゃうとうまくいかないんです
だからそれぞれ道具には使い方がありますから
体の場合もそれありますから
体は道具であるということははっきりしてほしい
また側変があります 例一つ満足の例を出します
ワンちゃんはお座り待てを理解するならば十分でしょう
これ楽しいでしょ？自分飼ってるワンちゃんにお座りって言ったら
何のことなく座ってくれると超楽しいでしょ
そこで何か美味しいものをでもあげてからはい待てと言っちゃうと
ワンちゃんが我慢していますっていうことはね
すごいお楽しいです しかし
今日は何曜日ですか？とワンちゃんに聞いてね
正解は求めませんね もし自分のワンちゃん
今日は何曜日？って言ったら
そいつは何も言わないでしょ？なんてアホなワンちゃんですかとかね
なんで私に限ってバカな犬になったのかどうか
これで悩む なんだら誰がバカですかね
だからワンちゃんにお座りできただけで十分でしょ
だから体も同じく使ってください
余計なことを体から期待しないでください
体の制限を正しく知って
これで満足することが理性であり
体の正しい使い方なんです
体には何でもできるものではありませんとよく知ることなんです
健康です 長生きすることができます
それで私は皆様おそらく狙いがあったでしょうね
あのどんな食べ物を食べた方が健康になるのかとかね
どんな食べ物を食べた方ががんが治るのかとかいったことは
すごい私も結構受けますけどね
そうすると入場券払わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
まあ 1万  2万  3万とかね
私も簡単で嘘を振らしちゃえばいいんです
嘘は人間が信じるんです
まあ事実だけは人間拒否するんだからね
それは冗談で言ったんだけども
で その世界忘れてください
これ食べたり まあ毎日きのこはこれぐらい食べた方がいい
ああいうリスト見てください
客観的に 1 日食べるべき
うーんと ファイバー 食物繊維はこれぐらいとかね 1
日で取るべきカロリーはこれぐらいとかね
計算して食事作ってみてください
牛食べても残るぐらい量なんです
だからそれが科学世界なんです
いかにアホかと しかし
日本の弁当はすごい賢くできてるんですよ
なんかちょこちょこといろいろあるんだけど
弁当食べたらちょうど次の時間になってくるとまたお腹が空くというね
あれはよくできていると思いますね
で だから問題は長生きする秘訣
健康での秘訣は満足すること
こんな程度やと  1万円持っている人が車会社に行ってポルシェリジャー注文するっていうのは変でしょ 1
万円だったら 1万円の買力はわかってるでしょうに
それで楽しい気分なら何が悪い？ 1万円あるんだからね
あれも買ってこれも買えるんだとかね
また 1,000円残っちゃったよとか楽しめるでしょ
だから我々はこの体から十分楽しめるチャンスあるのに
すべて見失っちゃって体壊してるんです
だからポイントは健康にいいからほうれん草食いなさいではなくて
健康にいいから納豆食べなさいではなくて
そんなのはどこも入ってるんだからね
健康というか 結局はダメになっちゃいます
だからそんなのは適当でいいんです
納豆を美味しく感じるならば
適当な納豆のものの見事に 1 日食べる量っていうのは小さなパッケージですから
問題ないんですよ だからばかりも健康でいられますよ
日本に住んでいるならば
でもそれは会社任せはできません
良くない 自分で考えてください
例えば弁当を食べるならば
栄養取り過ぎにはならないんですね
そう 他人任せは良くない
納豆買っちゃうとあのプラスチック箱だから
そこは一人分ですね その程度で体にいいんだけど
だからといって自分の修行ないでしょう
だからそこら辺で自分自身にもちょっと修行した方がいいと思いますね
そういうわけで 仏教的に言えば
これは食いなさい これは食ってはいけないっていうものに当たることは仏教はしない
心を管理しなさいと 程度よく生きる楽しみを受けなさいと
それで体壊れません はい
これ俗世間でそれで十分です
皆様が嫌になるかもしれませんだけど
これからもっと立派な世界の人間どうするのかと
知恵の開発を求める人間が
体どうやって取り扱うのかと
これから説明します  STAGE 2 価値編というんです
体をそれ分解してみる
分解ではなくて ちょっと直しましょうか
体を分解してみるんです
一般人があまりやりたがらないんだけどね
でも知恵が欲しければ
知恵を求めるならば分解した方がいいです
で あの皆様の生物学医学知識使って分解してもいいんですよ
でもそうすると一部の人にしかできなくなっちゃうんですね
医学を学んでいる人には
もう体の臓器一つ一つずつよくわかりますよ
そこに瞑想を入れちゃえばいいんだけどね
でもみんなにその知識がないんだから
これマハサティパッタナスッタンタという経典がありまして
本も出してますよ サティパッタナ経典のね
念処経の解説本とかね
ちょっと厚い本ですけどね
まあそれ読んだ方がいいと思いますけどね
この身随念というセクションがあります
そこを読んでみます 読んでみましょう
今日はできません 一応項目だけ書きます
1 呼吸の観察 体の一部でしょ
呼吸がなければ何もならないでしょ
そこで呼吸ってどんな機能でしょうか？どんな組織でしょうか
どういうふうにこれ起きているのかどうか
じっと見てみる そちらで命もないし
何もない ただ空気を出る
入る 出る 入る そこで感覚が生まれる
消える 生まれる 消える
生まれる 消える 空気が入る時の感覚と出る時の感覚は違う
そこでたくさんの空気が入る時の感覚と
たくさんの空気が出るときの感覚はそれぞれ違う
これで生きることになっているんだと理解すれば
たったこれだけで で 空気を入れる出すという繰り返しで体が成り立っていることを理解します
2番目の瞑想は立つ 歩く
座る 横になる また他のね
動きを観察する 単純な働きで体が機能していると理解する
体って言ったら大したことで
立つか歩くか 座るか 横になるかとかね
またいくつかいくつかね
行為があるんですね それだけですよ
それ以外何もできないんで
それは観察してみるんです
そこで 例えばなんで立ったのか
なんで歩くのかとかね
歩くということはどうやって成り立っているのかどうかね
精密に調べるんですね
はい 次  3番目の瞑想は
服を着る 服を脱ぐ 手を伸ばす
手を回してみる 食べる
飲むなどの細かい行為を観察する
生きるっていったっても
こんなもんでしょう やっているのは
とかね 服を着る時 こんなこんな感じで脱ぐ時はこういうこういう感じで手を伸ばしたり回したりする時ね
手だったら伸ばすか引くかしかできない
それから回す それから押すっていうことは
それも結局は力を伸ばすだけなんですね
例えば何か引くって これも強く手を捻るだけなんですね
だからエネルギーの問題なんですね
手を伸ばすという 手で押すという同じことなんですけど
伸ばす場合はエネルギーは少ない
押す場合はちょっと力強い
そんな差なんです うん
そういうことを観察してみるんです
何か飲む場合は どんな体の中
どんな働きが起きているのかとかね
食べる時はどんな働きが起きているのかとかチェックする
体とは大まかな行為と細かな行為で成り立っているのだと理解する
体って派手な行為もありますね
押すとかね 引くとかね
それからちっちゃなちっちゃな行為
いくつかありますよ すごく数えられるぐらい単純なものなんです
神様でなければわからないことは何一つもないんです
4番目のやり方は 体の細胞組織ごとに観察してみる
これは細胞組織ごとに見るんです
これは現代的な知識を使っても構わない
学校ででも勉強したことがあるならば
心臓組織は何なのか 肺という組織は何なのかどうかね
よく調べて こんな機能
こんな機能だとすぐ発見する
えらいシンプルであると
例えば肺っていうのは我々大げさに思ってるんだけど
なんのことない すごいシンプルなんです
ね で ろっ骨が大きくなっちゃうと空気が自動的に入っているだけで
入ってまた出ていく そうすると空気が交換するだけで
それなりに肺のちっちゃなちっちゃなすぶすぶのところで空気の入れ替えが起きている
すごいシンプルです しかし
この現代知識ない人にとってね
ブッダの瞑想っていうのはね
農民たちもね 奴隷の人々もね
使いもやっていたんだから
知識全くゼロの人々も
だからみんなにできるように
お釈迦様とか言われているんです
だから経典では 32臓器に分けています
それが医学的な分け方ではなく
体をちゃんと 32 には分けてあるんです
その分け方で観察すれば
誰にだって 体の観察はできるんです
体とは臓器の組み合わせです
それらは決して愛着が生まれるものではなく
嫌悪感 嫌悪感が作るんです
本当は体の臓器一つ取り出してみると
気持ち悪くなるんです
だから そのためにお釈迦様は 32 に分けたんです
だからお釈迦様の分解では心臓
肺臓も入ってますけど
きめ細かくやってないんです
例えば脳みそというだけで
脳の大脳とかね 中と原始脳とか
そういう分解性脳みそ
その代わりに胃袋ではなくて胃袋の中身とかね
それから鼻水とか尿とかね
便とか そういうふうに分けているんです
体にいつでもあるでしょう
便だけ取っちゃえ えらい気持ち悪いでしょ
でも持ち運んでいます
それは そうすると 体ってなんでこんな嫌悪嫌悪感が生まれるんだけど
愛着は生まれませんよと
気持ちになるんです それで 5番目の瞑想は
体は地水火風でできていることと
外の世界も地水火風でできていることを観察します
で あの 私は講演始めて元素で喋ったでしょ
11 のエッセンシャルエレメントでできているんだとかね
本当はちょっと理解しにくいんですね
炭素とか水素と言ったっても
よくわからないでしょう
本当は 無理やり学校でこれが水素ですよというで
見てもわからないね これが酸素ですよ
見てもわからない だからそれであまり感動はしないね
だからお釈迦様がものの見方を地水火風にしてくださいと
地水火風っていうのは
本当は素粒子のエネルギーなんですけど
そんななくてもいい 土
水 風 それでいいのだと
だから体ってこんな尊いものじゃなくて
地水火風ですよ 外の世界を見ても地水火風です
このテーブルは地水火風です
この体も地水火風です
何か違うこと こいつは感じない
こいつは感じる それだけ
差がないと理解する  6番目はちょっと現代人には難しい
死体を観察する 我が身の同じものであると理解する
本当に死体を見てほしい
死体を見て  死んだ死体だ
死んだ死体ではないね
死体だ これも感覚消えたら同じ死体だ
これが気持ち悪いんだったら
これも気持ち悪い これは腐ってるでしょ
こちらも感覚が消えたら腐っていく
だから有機体だから壊れるんです
感覚が壊れないようにしているんです
でも壊れないようにすることもできませんよ
だから新しいものを作るんです
で 経典では9つの死体のステージが書いてあるんです
日が経った 経った 経った死体
現代はなかなかこれはできないんですね
体とはただの地球の土であると理解すると
愛着に値しないのだとわかるので価値観が消える
これはちょっとアドバンスレベルですね
経験者 智慧を求める人々の取り扱いなんです
それで体っていうのは価値がないとわかる人は体に執着しない
そうすると体悪用しない
体から刺激くれ 刺激くれとは言わない
それで体が自然法則で健康で
病気にもかからないで寿命を全うすることができるんです
体に価値ゼロやとわかった人はそれで十分です
はい さらにステージ上げます
ステージ3 感覚編 これ説明しちゃうと今日のテーマから脱線しますからね
途中でやめます 有機物体に感じる能力があるから
命という機能が現れます
有機物体に感じる機能が現れたんです
それだけです 感覚がなければ
この物体に動き 働きあるいは機能はない
感覚なかったら何も機能しないんです
肥料と同じです 肥料も有機体でしょ
何もやらない 壊れるだけ
壊れるんだから 植物はそれ受け取る
だからこの体は感覚が抜けた途端
すっと有機体になっちゃって肥料になるんです
感覚が基本的に不安不満でなければ
体質 伸び縮みの働きは起こりません
そこで細胞に生成できることは
伸びるか縮むか 伸びる時は力を使うんだけど
縮む場合は自然に縮むんです
これは心臓を見るとよくわかります
心臓はものすごい力を使う
欲 ガクンと縮むんです
それからリラックスするんです
それで大きく膨らむんです
それから力いっぱい縮むんです
それからまたリラックスするんです
これで長生きするんです
だから 縮むことにも力を使って
膨らむことの力を使っちゃうと
もうすぐ死んじゃいます
2分ももたなくなっちゃうんです
そこで各細胞も同じなんです
伸びる 縮む 伸びる 縮む
伸びる 縮む なんで絶えず伸び縮みしているんですかと
感覚があるからなんです
だから感覚が何か嫌な感覚でないと仕事をやめちゃうんです
だから基本的に感覚は空楽
不空楽と分けても あれは即時にわかるように
基本的に感覚っていうのは大したことはないんです
不満なんです もし息を吸って満足したならば
そういう人はもう吐かないでしょ
だから息を吸ったら不満にならないと
吐かない 吐いちゃったら不満にならないとまた息を吸わないんです
だから感覚はそうやって何か気に入らない不満ということで命が成り立っているんです
だからお釈迦様は苦で命が成り立っていると
感覚が無常 苦 無我なので
愛着に値しないと発見します
だから肉体に愛着を捨てただけではなくて
あの進んだ人が智慧の進んだ人は
感覚にも心にも愛着捨てるんです
それでだいたいプログラムは終わると思います
はい それであの感覚編をその程度にします
それで悟りますからね
苦を乗り越えますからね
今日は感覚編を喋る時間じゃないんです
我々は道具のプロになりましょうと
道具っていうのは体ですね
小欲知足の世界 道具のプロになる秘密は小欲知足にあるんです
パーリ語でアッピッチャタサントゥッティと言うんです
しかし この小欲ってちょっと言葉がちょっと良くないんです
この場合の欲はグリードではなくニーズなんです
だからこの場合は英語の単語を入れないと
ちょっと差が言えないんですね
グリードって知ってるでしょ？欲張り
ニーズというのは必要
欲は少ないものも悪いんです
ニーズになるとリミットが成り立ちます
だから皆様 今まで欲で生きてきたでしょ？今日からニーズで生きてみてください
ものの見事に立派な人間になるんです
これは例で言います 水を飲んでるでしょ
時々欲で水を飲む人を見ますよ
2 リットルぐらい  1 日どうしても飲まなくちゃいかんとかね
それでガブガブ水を飲んで体を壊しちゃうでしょ
水もあまり飲み過ぎ良くないんです
あれは欲 ではなくて ニーズで喉が渇いてくる
水が必要になる 必要な量だけ入れる
お腹が空いてくる 食べるものは必要になる
必要な量だけ入れる 寒くなる
体冷える 余分な 1枚は必要になる
その程度にする これがブランドでなければいけませんとか
流行でなければいけませんとかね
私をすごいかっこいい人で見えなくてはいけないんだとかね
あれは全て間違いなんです
私は鏡の前でああ 結構かっこいいねと思ったってもね
皆様はダサい格好だと思ったらどうする？だからそんな無駄な努力なんです
だから理性ある人は 仏教徒はニーズで生きているんです
水がニーズになったら水を飲む
お茶がニーズになったらお茶を飲む
そういう感じで座ることはニーズになったら座る
足すことは必要だったら足す
で 我々は普通はテレビを見ながら
3時間も4時間も5時間も座ったままで
あれはニーズじゃなくて欲でしょ
それで健康が壊れるでしょ？知ったことじゃないんです
よくでやっちゃうんだから
ニーズでやってみたらどうですかね
疲れてきたらちょっと腰を掛けると気持ちいいよ
ソファでなくてもいいんです
で 座っていると ちょっと何か体がおかしくなってきて
ちょっと散歩をすると
これすごく気持ちいいんです
これでハチャメチャハチャメチャジョギングしちゃうと苦しくなるだけ
だからニーズでストップしてください
人間が病気になりませんよ
それだったら だから動物は病院作りませんね
人間だけでしょ 病院作っているのはなぜ？動物はもうニーズで生きているんです
動物も欲欲あるんだけど
でもそれはどうしようもないんですね
使えないんですね だからニーズだけで生きているんです
あの動物もあの猿もね
あのサツマイモに塩をかけたら美味しいんですよ
でも 猿に自分でサツマイモを塩をつけて食べることはできないでしょ
だから取ってそのまま食べたりはする
ゾウも同じなんですよ
ゾウに何か塩を入れてあげると
ハチャメチャ喜びますよ
危険です 象さんがこいつは本当に可愛いと思ってくれるんだからね
これは人間にとっておっかないんですね
ゾウさんに可愛がってくれるもんだから
ゾウさんとは自分の体力を知らないんだからね
でも だからそういう哺乳類の動物も塩をかけたらおいしく知ってますが
欲でいけないんですね
だから動物たちは病院作らないんです
はい 欲は満たせないと知る人はニーズを理解する
欲は満たせない ニーズは満たせる
それが最小限にします
そこでニーズに至っても
あの まあ最初 そのニーズは最小限になっています
例えば 美味しいものは食べると言ったら
リミットがない お腹に必要な燃料だけあげると思ったら
これぐらいという風にリミットがあるんです
この仏教でこの小欲っていうのは
このニーズのことなんです
お釈迦様の指令は 出家にはニーズも
最小限にしてください
例えば疲れて横になって寝る場合は
布団が欲しいとかね マットレスはなんだらかんだらとかね
マットレスでなければとかね
それってちょっと欲ニーズじゃないんですね
でもいくらかのマットレスあった方が体が痛くないんだから
その程度にしてください
出家にはどこかで横になれば十分だと
マットレスはこれも汚れるんだから
枯れ葉でも十分だよ 枯れ葉を拭いてあって
その上に寝る そうするとニーズは最小限でしょ
それで寝る時も眠気があると寝る
眠気がなくなったらさっさと立つ
ニーズも最小限にする
それは皆様には無理 だからまあニーズだけに
誰だってニーズだけにした方がいいんです
そこでサントゥッティという単語がある
喜び 満足って意味なんですね
サントゥッティというのは喜びなんですけど
この私は今日言葉 2つでいくんです
アッピッチャタ サントゥッティ
小欲知足 それだけですよ
体の取捨はすごいシンプルです
サントゥッティというのは喜びなんです
体から気のままに限りのない喜び
刺激 楽しみが決して得られない
これは得られない 限りのない喜びは得られない
限りのある喜びは得られる
例えば筋肉が硬くなっちゃうとマッサージすると気持ちいいでしょ
だったら 8時間もマッサージしてもらったらどう？相手を殺したくなるでしょ
苦しくて だからすべてリミットがあるんでしょうね
あのリミット以内で楽しんでください
肩が凝っちゃったら 10
分揉んでもらおう あの10分間筋肉をほぐしていること
なんて気持ちいいですか
はい さようなら 終わりと
そこで喜びだけで止まっちゃうでしょ
もうちょっとやれというのはとんでもないんです
体から得られる楽しみで満足することですね
体にはほんのわずかな楽しみをあげることはできます
それだけにしてくださいなんですね
仏道の人は刺激が刺激を命が維持できる程度にするんです
仏道になると刺激求めません
刺激がないと死んじゃうんです
だから死なない程度にしているんです
出家は今はないんだけどね
お釈迦様の時代の出家は
欲を期待しない 仏道の人は決して体から欲を期待しないが
刺激ないと死にますからね
生き続けるために必要な刺激だけ得て生活しているんです
はい 本当はあれで終わりたかったんだけど
また再度 1枚は入れたんですね
これは時間が余ったら喋ろうかなと思っていたんだけどね
体と業 あの業っていうのは心にある一つのエネルギーなんですね
心にある財産なんですね
だから心が体作るんですよ
有機物体が壊れないように修復するのは心ですから
心にも作るためにエネルギーが必要な
それを業というんですね
眼耳鼻舌身意の能力は業が決めます
だから私に見える範囲は私の業で決めています
皆様に見える範囲は皆様の業で決めています
だから全ては見えません
全ては聞こえません ということで
全て業の力なんですね
みんなに同じの だからみんなに同じ能力はありません
他人の能力で自分の能力を比較して悩んだり
落ち込んだり 嫉妬したりするのは無駄で悪行為です
あの人と同じく走りたいとかね
これは悪行為です あの人と同じく歌いたいとかね
悪行為です あなたの歌える能力は
あなたの業が決まっているんです
だからそこで満足しないと
体に不都合があっても仕方がありません
だから体にいろいろ不都合があるかも
生まれつき これは業がやったことだから
仕方がないんです それで
満足するしかないんです
アッピッチャターとサントゥッティが正しい生き方です
それで体の使い方はこの二言葉で終わります
アッピッチャタサントゥッティアッピッチャタというのは小欲
サントゥッティっていうのは日本語で知足と言いますけど
喜びなんで それで少ない楽しみで満足しなさいと
はい これで一旦終わるだろうとは思います
はいはい これで講演は終了です
えっと あの 自分なりに修行をしているつもりなんですが
あの やっぱり今日のお話とかも聞いて
生きることは苦しいし
体も維持するのは苦しいっていうのはあるんですけど
なんかやっぱり修行中に体がなくなる
心がなくなるっていうことが一体どういうことなのかとか
あと その なんだろう 生きるシステムから抜け出せるっていうことがすごいことなのかもしれないけど
ちょっと想像ですというか
自分にできるのかなっていうところで
すごくモチベーションがやっぱり落ちてしまうんですけれども
モチベーションを保つ秘訣というか
アドバイスがあれば教えていただきたいです
うん あの そういうシステムから抜け出すところは
人間の脳みそでは理解できない
なぜならば脳みそとシステムの中のものだからね
だからそれは別に気にしなくていいんですね
これで我々は派手に言っているのは
執着捨てなさいと 体捨てなさいではないんです
で 執着捨てましょうと
だから まあ放っておいて
そのまま流れるようにしておけば
だからなんで生きることは苦しいかというと
執着あるからなん 別に痛みで細胞が動いている
だからこれなくせないでしょ
細胞の中で楽しみが欲しいと思ったところで間違いなんですね
それは執着あるから変なことを期待したんですね
だから我々はまあ執着しないことにするんです
要するに まあ別にという感じで生きてみるんですね
別にという気持ちになることは
結構修行しないとできないんですね
だから我々は生きている上で結構失敗しますよ
あの失敗がすごくいいんですよ
失敗したら あ 私は別にと思ってないねとかね
そこでしたりすれば まあ次々進んでいくんですね
だからモチベーションっていうのは
人間に欲を言わなきゃできないことだから
特別モチベーションがなくてもいいんですね
あまり執着しないということだけやってみてください
はい  ありがとうございます
あ すいません あのお話の中で
人はみんな嘘はよく信じる
嘘をよく信じるけれど
本当のことはなかなか信じないとか理解しない
それなぜ  あ それはもう
自分の体に対する愛着でしょ
だから体に愛着あるんだから
愛着は持てないのに愛着を持ってる
そこで間違いがあるんです
体が有機物体なのに 私の体と思っている
そこも間違いなの それも嘘でしょ
それから自分が体が素晴らしい
体が神殿だ 体が神様が作ったありがたいものだ
体の仕組みは人間に理解できないほど複雑なものだというふうな嘘を言うと喜んで聞くんです
だから人は嘘を信じて事実を却下するのは
肉体に対して感覚に対して愛着あるからなんです
はい  はい それではそろそろちょうど時間になりましたので終了したいと思います
はい 最後の はい 一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェミンドゥッカ
バヤンパッタチェニンバヤ
ソーカッパッタチェニッソーカ
ホンテサンデーピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
長い時間どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
それでは これにて本日の正起仏教月例講演会
今年最後となりますね
もしかしたら今日が最後になる方も
今年は最後の方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
ぜひ良いお年をお迎えください
カンティ パラマン タポ ティティッカ ニッバーナ パラマン ワダンティ ブッダ